well my reaction to hearing about the
Nobel Prize was one of shock and
disbelief in fact I can remember very
very well when this happened I was
attending a meeting in California
meeting of the American Physical Society
and the optical Society of America
meeting jointly out in California in
Long Beach California
and the day before the prizes were
announced a number of us were sitting
around after the scientific sessions
were over speculating about who was
going to get the Nobel Prize that year
and believe me nobody brought up my name
so later that night well it was the
middle of the night that I got a call in
my hotel room to the effect that I had
shared the Nobel Prize with quad
cohen-tannoudji and Steve Chu came as a
complete shock
my life changed
dramatically it's very difficult for me
to keep up with all of the invitations
that I get to speak about my work the
size of my research group has has grown
that's made it possible for me to be
involved in more and more new kinds of
physics but it's made it harder and
harder for me to be intimately familiar
with all the things that are going on so
there's a kind of a tension between the
joy and doing lots of new things and the
desire to understand them better and
better another thing that I never would
have imagined would have been one of the
results of becoming a Nobel laureate is
that I ended up meeting people who are
actually famous so you know people say
oh you're a Nobel laureate it must be
famous no nobody remembers you know
outside of the field in which you're
working nobody remembers who won the
Nobel Prize even a couple years ago but
as a result of being a Nobel laureate I
get invited to two things where I've met
people who are actually famous one of
the people that I have met who has been
most charming is dr. Ruth Westheimer she
lives in New York City and I see her
probably about once a year and she's
just a wonderfully warm and a genuine
person just just a just a joy to know as
a friend